all right where' you get going all
right uh never been in a long-term
relationship where this this this CH
like if they're like 18 you're like well
good if they're like 50 you're like okay
never been in a long-term relationship
the age age matters so much our age okay
okay let's assume from now on that
what's on median age this this is this
is something that we are finding out on
a first date that we're on I think I'm
medium age right so it' be like 29 say
30 right 30 say 30 okay 30 years old
never been in a long consider
relationship what is long what is the
definition of a long relationship I'd
say like a year a year plus yeah a year
plus at least a year okay um o that's an
interesting one never been in a
long-term and we're not counting someone
who's just never been in a relationship
in general right uh are we counting that
cuz I feel like different I mean like
you can have a 30-year-old who who never
been in a relationship I think it's I
think actually it's very different
though being in many relationships as
opposed to being in that's what I'm
saying so like are we including that no
I wouldn't include that so they've been
in relationships before but none of them
have lasted longer than a year I'm going
yeah I'm going into this it because
they've never had a long term which
implies they've had relationships okay
sure okay um oh this is
tough okay I'm going to go never been in
a long-term relationship what's their
body
count well we can discuss this's the
body count what's the body count what's
the body count I'm kidding I'm kidding H
this is tough yeah this is hard all
right let me let me this is a very very
nuanced
AR okay I think I got my answer all
right Connie got yours okay ready three
two one I said none none I said red you
said red okay well let's let's start off
with you you're 30 years old yeah
presumably you've been in mult we pres
here's the all things I'm presuming I'm
assuming before we start yeah you 30
years old you've been in multiple
relationships none have made it to a
year yeah um who's the common
denominator
here what if that person say example
your partner right what if she was just
with seven really [__] boyfriends I
think the odds of that happening are so
much lower than you I
think listen I hate to be this person if
you if you've been with seven [__]
people I think you're the [__] person in
the you're the that is true you know
like think about it like whenever you
hear about someone cuz I think we all
have that one friend who has been in so
many relationships but never had
something solid and you're like you're
like after a while you're like man there
must be something that you're kind of
like not giving here or not
understanding about a relationship that
I think is given take sure I think a lot
of people you just sometimes you people
in life who just aren't very good at
like compromising and and doing that
kind of stuff um I can change them
that's why I wrote none listen I think I
think baby you won't need I wasn't the
comment actually I think n is the safe
answer but I'm I'm trying to be like I'm
trying to S conversation I'm the equal
side
this I'm thinking like from my
perspective if they've never been in one
I would be like okay I want to know
what's going on here cuz I think it's a
red flag as in like not like this is bad
I'm not going to talk to them more like
this is something that I want to kind of
pick that brain about more and figure
out what's Happening Here them it would
definitely be that I would want to know
about their past relationships and like
what happened so that I can figure out
like oh okay this could be an issue
going forward or like I can understand
that they weren't willing to compromise
on this or they could tell you the
person because some people genuinely
have just been with awful people and
they've been an like I you know I've
been in a bad relationship for a long
time you just get stuck in these things
but I think I'd love to talk about it
more yeah and I I say red but it's it's
not really yeah and I think that's why I
said none cuz like it really is it's
like a pink flag
it's not red as in like I'm not doing it
but I'm like I definitely want to know
what's up yeah it's like it's such a
case by case scenario with like every
single person there there is like
doesn't have people who have not dating
At All by the way this like if I hear
that it's kind of like it does raise a
flag it raises the flag of like context
what's what's the context what's going
on here yeah um because it could it
could be none and uh you know it could
be green it could be red we don't know
what the context of it can really slant
on the entire
Spectrum it can really slant on the
entire Spectrum depending on like you
know some sure you know in a very low
you know case scenario it might just be
the fact that they just got really
unlucky with their Partners who were all
[__] or the more common scenario is that
they're [__] right I mean yeah
relationships are tough a lot of the
time you're probably just doing
something small that that adds up over
time that's how
about communication right yeah I mean
it's all about communication I think
like another reason why it might not
mean anything at all it's just like
maybe their previous relationships they
just weren't at the right stage of life
to really fully commit you know some
people are just like actually I want to
commit to uh my career right now and I
don't have time for relationships go out
there find yourself you know yeah yeah
and then they they regen maybe it's cuz
I'm like the 30y old so if I hear that
I'm like okay this is about the age that
I've met around my friends where people
are like something like switches in
their brain to be like all right maybe I
should start you realize you know you
got to start you got to start figuring
this [__] out soon if you if you want to
um have children cuz you know you get
past 40 it becomes kind of kind of tough
so you got to you start figuring that
stuff out pretty soon absolutely it's
part of the be all right well that one
was that one there was no definite
answer in that one but good I want to
talk about it we got we got to talk
about call me fil the Frank because I
want to jump right into it I'm like
let's figure out what's going on all
right I just want to talk I just want to
talk I just want to talk let's talk
about all right next up what do we
got uh believes in super
itions ooh believes in
superstitions
um jeez I guess this is to like what
extent I feel like some everyone has
like a one Superstition they believe in
but if you're like let's let's say we're
going to assume this is like they are
very into superstitions Varan supersti I
would say more than normal okay then my
answer is going to change cuz I think
everyone has like a lot what's more
what's more than normal name me a
scenario you you're just never going to
feel good about someone opening an
umbrella
inside and that's right you try and open
up an umbrella and say they're like no
no no no yeah yeah but like that's a
normal that's generally quite normal in
Western countries yes so that's more of
like a conditioning thing than as
opposed to like actually believing that
something horrible is about to go wrong
I think that yeah so basically I thought
it was like ghosts and Sh Japanese
superstitions yeah superstitions
means no superstitions means like like
you believe in something that might
happen when there is no physical evence
for step on a crack break your mother's
back break your mother's back which is
absolutely ridiculous they could CH
something better but believe that [__]
when I was like four uh all right all
right okay I think I think we're all
going to say the same thing here yeah
okay ready 3 two one
beig a quy thing I don't have a lot to
say about this other than
sure this is just all Japanese people
yeah Japanese people culture and
surrounding way too much to the point
where like you know I could be at my
aunt's house I try and open up an
umbrella and she'll be like don't think
that's a good idea and I'm like why I
mean I mean I mean this is I mean this
is a lot of Asian households there are a
lot of weird Asian superstitions I don't
know how many Western superstitions
there are you know uh step on a crack
break your mother's back I remember that
one uh what is it a ladder and doors is
it no if if a black cat crosses your
path then it's bad luck or something as
walking underneath a ladder or something
walking underneath the ladder smart
safety yeah I wonder where the Black Cat
Came From it's like I think it just came
from the idea of like you know uh at
least in Japan I think where it came
from was like you know a black cat is
the same color as a crow and crows are
usually not a great symbol you know like
symbol of death and stuff like that so I
think it's just I feel also also you
know cats I think were always like just
a target for superstitions ever since
like you know people used to call each
other witches back in the day being like
Oh you own a cat you must be a witch cuz
I feel like all superstitions come from
somewhere you know because like I don't
know if it okay here's usually from
someone just smoking crack here's the
thing like I don't I don't think every
Superstition came a lot of it here's the
thing like I don't know if there been
like something that's conditioned into
me but like most superstitions are kind
of like I don't believe in them but I do
agree that they're not good vibes you
know like the
energy positive super station uh
generally no no no no everything is
based on something and that's something
I don't I I'm pretty sure it just
something about bad vibes you know I
don't believe anything that's is going
to happen when you open an umbrella
inside but I see an umbrella that's open
inside I'm like oo I I don't I don't I
don't I don't like this I don't like I
don't like this I don't know why I just
don't like it you know I don't I don't
like this it's just unnatural yeah and
when you like walk and like maybe this
is my ADHD but when I notice that I'm
stepping on cracks I'm just like what if
I just what if like what my mom what
what what what if the smooth part of my
brain is just like oh but what if I step
in between the cracks you know you know
what I mean you know it's the [__] I
used to do when I was like five no
exactly exactly it just feels when it's
like a tiled flooring and you're just
like stepping on a perfect like Step
Mania feels nicer to like like once you
like consciously observe it oh totally
yeah yeah I I get it I get it
superstitious people I get it's just a
bit weird but it's not a deal Breer yeah
all right let's see let's let's check
out the next
one all right here we go all right what
flag is uh a partner that can't handle
losing as in they're a sore
[Music]
loser um all
right soul loser all
right three right two one red
red red red oh okay we're all red okay
okay I mean yeah it's uh Soul loser is
just never a positive thing that's
that's not even a partner thing that's a
red that's a red flag as a uh as a
friend losing is part of you got to lose
yeah losing is how you get better the
worst thing about a soul loser is just
how much of a Vibe killer they become
you know yeah yeah that's the worst part
I the thing I hate more than people who
hate losing are people who won't even
try because they don't want to lose at
something yeah that's the thing I hate
the most when like you won't even play
something cuz you know you're not going
to win and thus you're not going to play
and then you be like this [__] stupid
anyway so whatever I that no like the
thing the thing I think that is like
even worse than that because no no one
likes losing or anything but when when I
hear someone that hates losing right if
you have to if you hate losing there's
there's I've been enough around enough
people where they lose at something and
they kind of just like shut down as a
human being they're just pissed and they
want to bring the vibe down because they
are having an awful time for losing at
some kind of game or something want go
again I'm like let me play again I'll
beat you this time double or nothing I
don't know I it's F it's fun getting
better at stuff why would you not want
to get better or something well just
some people just want to be just perfect
at everything you know and they want to
look like the perfect human and just
life doesn't work that way to me maybe
it's not someone who hates losing
someone who's a s loser that is that is
such a big Vibe killer if a s loser I'm
I'm not going to throw a strop about it
I'm like let's [__] play again let's
go no
yeah sure all right all right well that
one was pretty unanimous oh that was
that was pretty that was pretty easy
though that was pretty easy who who
thinks man that's sexy this is sexy when
they wh love when someone love when they
get
pissed like a little [__]